l'ordre du jour appelle la question
orale numéro 243 de Madame Joël
gariomella ma madame la garde des sceaux
ministre de la justice merci monsieur le
président madame la ministre
heureuse
la fin l'occasion de vous interroger sur
cette question des litiges familiaux
transfrontaliers ayant déposé une
question écrite à ce sujet il y a près
d'un an j'avais également depuis
déposer une question écrite sur
l'exécution par la France demanda
d'arrêt allemand émis pour l'exécution
pour recouvrer pardon une créance
alimentaire d'environ 5000 euros
question restez également sans réponse
je lis dans ces retards une certaine
gêne qui me semble injustifiée en
pointant les drames humains engendrées
par les divorces transfrontaliers je ne
cherche en aucune façon astigmatiser
telle ou tel état je me réjouis
d'ailleurs qu'une grande partie des
divorces binationaux se résolvent sans
drame reste des cas certes minoritaire
mais dramatique pour des enfants de
couper de tout lien avec l'un de leurs
parents et l'idée les problèmes ne me
semble pas une attitude resp
l'Allemagne n'est pas la seule concernée
il ne s'agit nullement de dénigrer les
pratiques de nos partenaires mais
devrait en faveur d'une harmonisation
minimale des législations familiales le
droit de la famille constitue certes une
prérogative souveraine des États mais le
principe juridique de l'intérêt
supérieur de l'enfant est inscrit dans
le droit international maintenir des
contacts personnels avec les deux
parents la fratrie et les grands-parents
constituent un droit fondamental des
enfants le droit d'être élevé dans le
respect des deux langues aussi les
accords européens Bruxelles de bises ou
Rome 3 ont constitué une avancée
appréciable en limitant les possibilités
de recours au tribunal le plus
avantageux mais ils ont aussi des effets
pervers en permettant l'application
automatique des décisions d'un autre
État membre n'aurait-il pas fallu
construire un socle minimal commun en
matière de justice familiale avant de
supprimer les exéquats tours quelle est
la volonté de la France de pousser des
efforts d'harmonisation des justices
familiales en Europe concrètement dans
quel instance pourront se dérouler ces
négociations
face aux tensions observer au Parlement
européen lorsque ce thème a été abordé
ne serait-il pas opportun de créer une
plateforme favorisant un travail serein
mais franc en bilatéral ou en
multilatérales par exemple une
commission rassemblant des responsables
des administrations concernées
professionnels de justice familiale
parlementaire défenseurs des droits et
des enfants des États concernés elle
pourrait travailler à la convergence des
législations et des pratiques mais aussi
favoriser un déblocage sur les dossiers
les plus sensibles par exemple quand des
autorités étrangères refusent de
reconnaître des décisions de justice
française
organisé des coopérations entre
professionnels de justice familiale
entre État membre pour également
favoriser une harmonisation par le bas
par ailleurs des efforts pour être menés
à l'échelle franco-française je pense
notamment l'institution d'un contrôle de
proportionnalité avant l'exécution d'un
mandat d'arrêt européen celui-ci ne sert
pas explicitement prévu par la
réglementation européenne mais plusieurs
pays l’appliquent répondent en cela
préoccupations et non c'est par la
commission qui s'inquiète de la
multiplication des mandats d'arrêts
européens pour des infractions mineures
je pense également à la définition d'un
interlocuteur susceptible d'accompagner
les parents dans les méandres de la
coopération judiciaire internationale et
de les orienter vers des organismes
adaptés lorsque l'autorité centrale
s'estime non compétente dans de nombreux
cas les parents ne trouvent pas auprès
de cette autorité centrale le soutien et
l'orientation dont ils ont besoin
aujourd'hui 13% des couples européens
sont binationaux cette proportion ne
cesse d'augmenter l'enjeu est
considérable nous ne pouvons plus fermer
les yeux les enfants d'aujourd'hui
feront les adultes de demain en Europe
merci la parole est à Madame Christiane
Taubira garde des sceaux ministres de la
justice
merci monsieur le président
madame la sénatrice messieurs les
sénateurs madame la sénatrice je suis
profondément désolée que notre rencontre
ne s'effectue qu'aujourd'hui vous avez
bien que je n'ai aucune influence sur le
calendrier parlementaire et en
l'occurrence sur celui du Sénat donc je
me présente à vous parce que cette
question était inscrite à la séance de
ce matin c'est avec plaisir que je
réponde à votre question encore que j'ai
noté qu'elle a substantiellement changé
de contenu puisque dans votre question
écrite telle qu'elle a été enregistrée
vous évoquez essentiellement des
pétitions qui étaient
adaptés présentés devant le Parlement
européen et qui montrait à quel point le
comité de la jeunesse allemand
intervenait et en fait aboutit
permettait d'aboutir des décisions
insatisfaisantes vous êtes dans une
autre dynamique dans votre question
aujourd'hui puisque vous proposez la
mise en place d'une commission vous
proposez un certain nombre de
dispositifs qui permettrait de voir les
choses ambilatérales de façon plus
efficace mais peut-être aussi en
multilatérale puisque vous j'ai dit
vous-même la question n'est pas comme
vous l'aviez dit écrit dans votre
question écrite essentiellement avec
l'Allemagne mais d'une façon générale et
c'est ce que je confirme avec tous les
pays alors nous avons évidemment le
souci de l'harmonisation du droit sur
lequel peut le droit qui peut peser sur
ces familles nous avons des principes
juridiques communs avec ceux de la
Convention internationale des droits de
l'enfant que la France a signé et
ratifier ses principes entendent que
dans l'intérêt supérieur de l'enfant et
ça s'exprime expressément défini dans
l'article 9 de la Convention
internationale que dans l'intérêt de
l'enfant les liens directs et réguliers
soit maintenu avec le parent absent
alors nous n'avons pas de droit commun
avec tous ces pays en particulier avec
l'Allemagne l'Union européenne n'a pas
un droit commun pour la simple raison
que le droit de la famille ne relève pas
de sa compétence elle ne peut donc pas
concevoir un instrument juridique qui
s'imposerait à tous les états nous avons
quelques accords zéro il y a par exemple
accord bilatéral sur le régime
matrimonial optionnel de la
participation aux acquets mais en
matière d'autorité parentale il n'y a
pas d'accord bilatéraux et en toute
franchise vous connaissez assez le sujet
pour je crois avoir la même appréciation
que moi il y a une réelle difficulté
contenue du fait que dans l'autorité
parentale intervient des éléments qui
sont liés à l'histoire à la culture à la
sociologie pour autant nous ne sommes
pas démunis même si j'ai bien entendu
l'appréciation très relative que vous
portez sur nos instruments européens et
internationaux nous avons évidemment
d'abord la convention de la haie qui
concerne l'enlèvement d'enfant qui
permet à la juridiction du pays où
l'enfant était déplacé de décider du
retour immédiat et qui permet à cette
juridiction de prendre des mesures pour
veiller à la protection du droit de
visite cette convention internationale
de 1980 a été complétée par Bruxelles de
bises que vous avez évoqué c'est-à-dire
le règlement de 2003 qui permet la
compétence la reconnaissance et
l'exécution des décisions aussi bien en
patrimonial qu'en matière d'autorité
parentale c'est d'une certaine façon
quand même une norme juridique commune
parce que cette norme juridique qui
s'impose puisque le règlement s'impose à
tous les pays européens ce règlement
permet notamment de prévenir quelques
risques de décision contradictoires et
de garantir la circulation des décisions
enfin nous avons la convention de la
haie de 1996 qui établit que l'autorité
parentale définie dans un pays se
maintient en cas de déménagement dans
l'autre pays alors sur le plan pratique
parce que évidemment je me suis dit le
droit vous le connaissez comme moi je
peux simplement vous confirmer qu'il y a
des efforts d'harmonisation mais qui ne
peuvent pas se faire au-delà évidemment
de Bruxelles de bises pour l'instant
mais il est bon de regarder les chiffres
alors
il y a quand même une certaine
contradiction entre les pétitions le
nombre de pétitions qui sont présentés
au Parlement européen
les les alertes que vous recevez
manifestement votre qualité de sénatrice
et je sais depuis plusieurs années à
quel point vous êtes mobilisés sur ces
sujets et puis les chiffres que nous
avons effectivement au bureau d'entrée
de civils et commercial international
qui relève de la Chancellerie alors j'ai
entendu votre observation concernant le
la tendance de ce bureau à
se déclarer non compétent
ce n'est pas ce que révèle les chiffres
parce que les chiffres révèlent pour
l'Allemagne alors comme votre question
concernait l'Allemagne je les ai fait
sortir pour l'Allemagne je vous les
donnerai je vous laisserai la note donc
j'indique très très rapidement
simplement que
le nombre de dossiers est à peu près
équilibré entre pays et les décisions de
retour aussi sont à peu près équilibrés
voilà donc ça veut dire que notre bureau
s'empare bien des dossiers qui lui sont
confiés et procède donc à leur règlement
donc en 2011 nous n'avons pas des masses
de dossier nous avons 8 dossiers qui ont
été clôturés en 2011
et en 2012 deux dossiers ont été
clôturés à ce jour il y a 6 dossiers en
cours les dossiers qui sont en cours
date de 2012 et de 2013 qui nous donne
une indication sur les délais de
traitement de ces dossiers ça c'est côté
Allemagne requis c'est-à-dire demande
France côté demande Allemagne et France
requise cinq dossiers ont été colloturés
en 2011 12 l'ont été en 2012 de
pour retour et les 9 autres clôtures et
c'est intéressant de voir les raisons on
a parmi les motifs le désistement ou la
carence du requérant on a également le
caractère manifestement mal fondé de la
demande et on a parfois heureusement un
accord trouvé entre les parents je dis
heureusement parce que c'est contentieux
familiaux sont extrêmement douloureux
ils le sont à l'intérieur de l'espace
judiciaire européen ils le sont ailleurs
aussi parce que nous avons des
conventions bilatérales avec d'autres
pays et je peux vous dire que c'est le
contentieux le plus difficile à telle
enseigne que j'ai mis en place des
commissions bilatérales qui se
réunissent parfois à Paris il y a des
pays avec lesquels les relations
interrompues depuis 5 6 10 ans donc j'ai
enclenché tout cela parce que c'est
extrêmement douloureux il y a toujours
un parent qui est malheureux parfois
l'enfant l'est aussi et donc ce sont des
contentieux qu'il faut évidemment
manipuler avec la rigueur du droit mais
également la délicatesse que suppose la
nature du sujet je propose que nous nous
revoyons pour voir ensemble comment nous
pourrions mettre en place les
propositions que vous faites dans la
question que vous avez
prononcé tout à l'heure donc qui sont
des des offres d'organisation du travail
supplémentaire par rapport à la première
interrogation que vous m'avez adressé
merci Madame la Ministre madame guerriot
mélames oui madame la mini je vous
remercie beaucoup de votre réponse et de
ses avancées ce sont des cas
effectivement
d'où là nous avons tendance à nous
réfugier derrière certains chiffres qui
sont effectivement peu importants mais
qui cache en fait la réalité du problème
d'une part une vie est une vie ces
questions vous l'avez souligné vous-même
madame la ministre sont extrêmement
douloureux et nous avons des situations
absolument tragiques d'enfants privés
d'un de leurs parents et je crois qu'il
faut vraiment que nous essayons
d'avancer avec le plus de pragmatisme
possible vous avez cité ces commissions
bilatérales que vous avez mises en place
je vous en remercie et je vous en
félicite nous avions une commission
bilatérale avec l'Allemagne qui était
une commission parlementaire mais qui a
été supprimée en 2005 au prétexte que
l'accord de Bruxelles de BIS supprimer
les problèmes or ce n'est pas le cas
puisque nous continuons à voir ce type
de problème je voudrais souligner aussi
que beaucoup de parents connaissant la
difficulté de l'entreprise sont rendent
en compte
laisse pas alerter les autorités
françaises parce qu'ils savent qu'ils
n'auront peut-être pas les moyens
d'assurer leurs défenses d'assurer le
coût d'un avocat et très souvent il
renonce ou arrive à des situations un
petit peu désespérées dans les vêtements
d'enfants comme nous l'avons vu donc
vraiment je vous remercie beaucoup de
votre proposition je serai très heureuse
de travailler avec vous nous avons déjà
travaillé sur d'autres sujets
l'élimination munition totalement
différent mais je connais votre
détermination et je vous remercie
vraiment beaucoup de cette avancée merci
Madame